I don't want to get shot no no no I
don't wanna I don't wanna die
[Applause]
is this like a morale booster yes it's
also really fun to play nerf games why
do we play this game cuz it's fun to
play nerf games Jake had to write too
many emails as well I do when I start
writing too many emails we were
discussing the other day what elves do
in their off time when it's not
Christmas we came to an answer there's
an ongoing war with the southern elves
who protect and defend Jack Frost things
have gotten so bad with the war with
Jack Frost that Santa has assembled a
crack team of his best elves to sneak
down and eliminate Jack Frost from the
South Pole in the off season now here's
the problem you're only gonna be armed
with this you're gonna have to sneak
into Jack Frost's warehouse past armed
century guards who will be blindfolded
but can hear problem is your hat has
bells on it exactly I think you get the
idea
steal a key sneak into his personal
quarters take him out with this without
waking him up sneak out and get away
clean and here's the thing wait if we
get shot do we do we get to try it again
straight up dead I don't want to get
shot any true secret Asian elf does not
divulge his true identity so I'll be
known as John Doe or enough name is
sprinkle Stiltskin I'm queasy mix queasy
[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm Jack Frost I feel pretty good
about my chances of survival here
because I got great centuries I took the
best ones that put them in this room and
I'm a pretty light sleeper in addition I
keep my ice dagger on me at all times
I feel like between all the defenses I
have going on I'll be fine I'm gonna
sleep easy tonight a couple elves I mean
come on dude like no confidence that
looks so difficult
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna try to change it up a little
bit so I'm gonna try a couple different
methods first I'm actually gonna go
around the side of the ramp and climb
mine up went over the the gate there I'm
also gonna remove my shoes so buy more
control over the ground my feet
[Music]
go
and I think just a straight shot to the
Jack Frost now that we have three crack
elves through the first phase it's time
to go test their real capabilities stay
tuned in a laboratory to wizard
scientists forcefully dragon elf to a
large metal press no no no I don't wanna
I don't want to die now a third
scientist helps hold him down as the end
presses a large debris button operating
the press the press comes down and as
soon as it makes contact with the elf
blue magic pops out of it
slamming the press down to the metal
base as the elf disappears cut to the
wide shot of a group of Tor guests
looking on in shock as an overly excited
tour guide claps hands yes yes yes yes
what a magical experience I'm wearing
with miss Adrienne's first pass on his
rock video is complete so we're gonna go
out there and take a look at it I expect
it to be well shot because he's a great
cinematographer I expect it to look
pretty which is part of it being well
shot and then also hopefully it
accomplishes what he sought to create I
mean I'm not nervous because it's a
rough cut and I know it there's gonna be
notes but you know I hope they like it
wouldn't bored of this so I put the
sound effects in and hopefully it works
now gather around yawn aah - I know it's
great is that this video is gonna come
out Monday Fred this video is Monday a
week from Monday yeah yeah but that's
not gonna come out on Monday what's
happening
[Music]
I think the overall flow that works
really well beginning hooks me it starts
to slow down I start to feel T's de
Lobos audience member and when it comes
to YouTube others skip ahead doesn't
want to avoid that happening the ending
feels pretty good actually
Adrienne made what he sought to make
that is extremely difficult to do
especially in the setting in which it
was done a bunch of production logistics
were against him he was shooting a lot
in a little amount of time he was
working with a new crew he's coming into
a new company it's his first video
there's a ton of pressure his experience
in having filmed everything else that
he's made I think really helped him out
most features can't even do that with
hundreds of millions of dollars we've
given him our notes that we collectively
came up with he's gonna sit down with
Nico tomorrow go over them try to
implement some of them and we'll see
what he does with them and I think it'll
be good I said use my audible
integration time to actually clean the
camera room it's the only chance I have
to do it I need to find this cable
another audible integration another
chance for me to recommend to you one of
my favorite books I've really been
wanting to recommend that you read Snow
Crash I read it this fall and it blew my
mind
there's pizza delivery boys that if they
don't get the pizza there on time they
die sick motorcycle races a big floating
aircraft carrier raft there's also mini
guns audibles introduced a new feature
that's actually kind of cool you now
listen to it on your Amazon echo Alexa
read Snow Crash the wide specs on
television screen resulting from weak
recent Alexa pause so now you can just
talk to your echo I have to be careful
not to say the q''-word otherwise it
starts listening to me you can listen to
audiobooks on your echo anywhere you are
and it's really cool because you
actually resume it on your phone right
from where you left off or any other
device that you're listening on it keeps
track of your progress through the story
and keeps all your devices synched up
what are these when we have helicopter
headphones like actual functioning ones
Snow Crash
is a book about the future but also
about the past part of takes place in a
weird ultimate history America Pardo
takes place in the VR Metaverse
and part of it takes place in history
I'm talking about linguistics so for
example when you think what do you think
about things they think about solving a
problem you tend to think in the
language that you speak I guess I do you
know I think I think in English the book
poses a question which is what about in
the origin of language when there wasn't
past tense in future tense and pronouns
the vocabulary wasn't that big did that
affect how well people could think and
how well they could problem-solve and
actually it's a really interesting
question to pose and in the book then
ties that into a sci-fi twist where it
gets into the depths of hacking how
people's minds function and if there's a
language that allows you to do so so I
highly recommend you check it out so
you'd actually try it right now for free
if you have an Amazon echo just simply
ask Alexa to read you a book now right
now Alexa you can also go to audible.com
slash Sam and Nico or text Sam and Eko
to five hundred five hundred to get a
free book and a free one-month trial man
I'm never gonna find that cable now that
boy is gone it's too bad it's really
really useful because we could put her
at her master's doesn't have a battery
panel that's how we were plugging it
into batteries and somebody straight-up
lost it what's this why is this here
steal a key sneaked into his personal
quarters take him out with this without
waking him up sneak out and get away
clean there's no God only Santa
[Music]
[Applause]
I lie here I'm sleeping I'm sleeping
away and all I hear is one little Bell
goat I open one eye and Nico's right
there and he like looks at me and he
sees my eyes are open he goes so Neko
technically still accomplished the
mission he died a war hero and they made
a statue for him in the North Pole
looked like but it's so funny to see you
like now Nikko died a war hero but
Adrian has the chance to live as a war
hero we'll see what happens
no pressure three two one game on
[Music]
you just like I wouldn't wake me as
possible because when I was up there I
had no idea
Nikko made it that in that quick so like
if I go even quicker they're probably
not gonna have any idea oh my god
I really just walk this way and like
that at this Beach dude I didn't think
I'd make it through that first challenge
both oh here's the thing though both
Nico and Adrian basically made it to the
end
Nico died out of sheer bad luck Adrian
made it and his method was to go really
fast but if I go really fast I'm afraid
I'll be hurt I'm gonna try the shoe this
game on
[Music]
[Applause]
for the kill is like I have no weapon
Jack Frost slow ice dagger beats an
unarmed elf every day
Adrienne was the only one to make it
home alive through your senses top elf
now until next time Christmas is save
takes yeah till next winter
sweetie well that was a lot of fun now
if you think we should play that again
let us know hey consider subscribing if
you haven't already